you have had a pretty successful
independent rap career yeah I spoke with
ad about this a few weeks ago and he was
essentially saying like man this
personality [__] I've made like 10 times
more than I've ever made sex is are you
in that same boat I'm super in that boat
yeah I was in that boat before him but
yeah yeah but definitely it I found
that's why I started doing the Mac eats
and that's why I started that's why I
fully kind of just went that lane
because it just takes too much as a rap
artist you got to put too much money you
gotta do you gotta invest all of the all
of that into it and you're not sure if
you're gonna you know I'm saying you're
gonna get any money back and then you
might not get any money back for a few
years also and if you do then you have
to sign a deal I mean you probably gotta
sign a deal and everybody's got their
hands in your pocket you know what I'm
saying versus this this you don't really
need to do [__] you just turn get a
computer and and you know what I look at
Tim is like I feel like you guys like
you guys like A.D who like have like
like fans you guys [__] successful
artists independently but like that
music almost was like um
a an investment into getting people
interested into who you are right which
makes it able which makes you able to go
on Vlad and make sure to go it and now
be your own you know your own YouTube
yeah so it's just growing it's just the
growth and just being able to reinvent
yourself for me and I think that's like
as you know that's that's a trait that
is necessary for survival in this game
but any in life in life yeah you got to
be able to reinvent yourself I'm curious
you go on Vlad often would you say a few
times a year yeah I haven't been on Vlad
for a minute but were you ever a part of
his like paying regular guest program
yeah so you would get a bag for each
interview yeah I always get a bag over
there nice yeah shout out to Vlad man
yeah shout out to Vlad man I don't know
I mean that's like if it works right I
mean because I think a lot of people
probably give him like a a bad rep but
to me it's like I don't know many other
platforms that like
monetarily cut you in on but he said
that since he started doing that his
[__] exploded even more he made even
more money well because if it's working
right you know like with boozy right
yeah every boozy interview like goes
crazy come on and he clips that [__] a
million times and clips it crazy he's
the he's he started that he's the clip
God he's the cliff God shout out to
shout out to Vlad no he's the reason why
we clip our him and Joe Rogan the reason
we clip our [__] right it makes sense I
think who did it first vladder Joe Rogan
I think Vlad did for sure no I think
Vlad did that for sure yeah Vlad started
doing it he he everybody was like at
first when I saw that I was I didn't
understand like I mean but you know once
I started looking at the numbers you
look up your stuff I mean for my uh for
your interviews for my interviews yeah
yeah yeah I mean yeah he's still a new
way yeah yeah shout out to laugh for
that man so when you're like uh okay so
what is your I'm curious just from like
being on this side of things when you
hit the road yeah you just decide to do
a Mac eats right yeah what does your
team look like how many people are
hitting the road with you how many
cameramen do you got like what is your
like setup like what is your kind of
like your your school it depends where
I'm going you know I mean um it depends
where I'm going but usually bro I'll go
with my cameraman and I'll go with
myself and maybe one homie and you know
what I'm saying and and whatever else we
need one camera every time
One camera every time that's what I do
one camera great yeah getting some great
[__] any have you guys ever fly drones
I mean uh we have yeah we have a few
episodes yeah sure yeah what it's like
for you is the goal to eventually
because I I think YouTube is the new TVs
when people are like oh I'm gonna make
it on TV I don't give a [__] right yeah
nobody cares about you no one gives a
[__] it's like nobody cares about radio
yeah respectfully as someone who's on
the radio in 18 cities no one gives a
[__]
um but um
for you what is like the because we've
seen Action Bronson do this kind of
first right with [__] that's delicious
and he's turned that into
restaurants and food trucks and books
and right all that like for you what do
you want to take Mac eats in terms of
like you know how like how do you want
to scale this thing man
I mean all that like I'm gonna do a
restaurant you know what I'm saying do
some sauces you know what I mean the
sauces will go crazy sauces you know I
mean do different stuff like you know I
mean the sky's the limit honestly like
you know I don't know I might I might do
whatever but have you had any offers to
do any TV stuff yet with TV stuff yeah
like I'm sure I have yeah yeah but I
just you know turned it down yeah I'm
not really
you know what I'm saying like like you
said the TV stuff is like you know we
making money on this like if it's not if
it's not gonna be like a super big
situation or if it's not going to be a
super big bag then why would I you know
I mean like I think I I I'm waiting for
the best for the right thing to come
along yeah I feel like for you it would
make sense if it was like a prestigious
like Netflix situation right like
something like that because even
something that's really going to put me
it'll it'll it'll raise your profile and
it'll raise your funds in every other
capacity right you know what I mean
right so